hello everyone and welcome to this
session of bitcoin mining my name is
saurabh and i'm part of the simply learn
team so
what's in it for us today we need to
know what is bitcoin
we will understand the underlying
technology blockchain so we will talk
about that
then we will see what are the advantages
of bitcoin as compared to other digital
currencies
and other digital technologies then we
will go into the concepts of bitcoin
mining
then what is bitcoin mining and we will
do a demo on
certain aspects of bitcoin mining now
what is bitcoin bitcoin
is the first decentralized digital
currency
that allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer
without any intermediaries like banks
governments agents brokers nothing is
involved
and all this is done using blockchain
technology so as we saw in our previous
example
two parties wants to exchange money
transfer money
they don't need an intermediary now
bitcoin can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument
and it can be primarily used for
payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009
it came into existence by a person or a
group of people
called satoshi nakamoto now bitcoin
helps transferring of assets
faster than regular fiat currencies
it has definitely lower transaction fees
because as it has removed the
intermediaries from between
the cost of transaction also goes down
and it is cryptographically secure
it uses cryptography infrastructure and
thereby the identities
of the sender and the receiver are also
secure and
entire transaction is cryptographically
signed and the users
information who are doing the
transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden
and secure now what are the advantages
of bitcoin
so it allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions
it is impossible to counterfeit or hack
the transactions which are running on a
bitcoin network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions
or charging a fees in order to validate
the transaction it is the
participants in the decentralized
network who are taking care of the
sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information
is accessible to public it is available
publicly on a public ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the bitcoin network
and it is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other
mediums and channels through which today
digital transactions are made now what
is blockchain so bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger
in which transactions made in bitcoins
or
any other digital currency are recorded
in a chronological order so let's see
certain features
it is cryptographically secure signed
using your private key and then
shared on the network with the public
key it is immutable
any record or any transaction added on
the blockchain cannot be modified or
altered
it is run by a decentralized system
there is no centralized authority of the
body
and the transactions are stored in
containers
aggregated in containers called blocks
so
a block is the smallest unit of a
blockchain
which records all the transaction a
basic structure of a block
is something like this it has four
fields these are the primary attributes
for block
it has something called as previous hash
so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block
and that's how the blocks are linked to
each other
data this is the aggregated set of
transactions
which are included in this block so
these are the set of transactions
which were mined and validated and
included in the block
nonce so in proof of work consensus
algorithm
which is used in bitcoin nonce is a
random value
which is used to vary the output of the
hash value
so every block is supposed to generate a
hash value and nonce is the parameter
which is used to generate that hash
value
and the proof of work is the process of
transaction verification
done in blockchain now hash is the
resultant hash value
obtained by passing the previous hash
value
the data and the nonce through the
sha-256 algorithm to generate the hash
of this block so this is the digital
signature of the block
which is generated and this is the
basically identity of this block
now sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces
a unique 256-bit alphanumeric hash
value for any given input and that is
the unique feature of this cryptographic
algorithm whatever
input you give it will always produce a
256 bit hash
now let's understand the concepts of
bitcoin mining what is bitcoin mining
bitcoin mining is the process of
verifying
bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public
blockchain ledger in blockchain the
transactions
are verified by bitcoin users
so basically the transactions have to be
verified by none other than the
participants of the network
those who have the required hardware
and computing power and those entities
are called miners so we will be talking
about them later
but the point to be highlighted is that
there is nothing like a centralized body
as in case of legacy transactions where
we used to be dependent on
a regulatory or governing body or a bank
to make our transactions go through now
in bitcoin here
any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart
that kind of computer can be a
participant and contribute to the
mining community process is solved based
on a difficult mathematical puzzle
called proof of work so every miners
job is to solve the mathematical puzzle
which is called proof of work in order
to validate the transaction
and earn the reward and all the miners
as they are competing amongst themselves
to mine
a particular transaction the miner who
first solves the puzzle
gets the reward now users trying to sell
the puzzle as i said are called miners
they are the participants in the network
who have the necessary hardware
and computing power to do all the
transactions to validate the
transactions and validate it they are
called as
miners now in order to understand
bitcoin mining we need to understand
three major concepts of blockchain it is
based on distributed public ledger
it uses sha-256 encryption algorithm
and proof of work is the underlying
consensus
algorithm for bitcoin mining so
distributed public ledger a distributed
ledger is a record
of all transactions maintained in the
blockchain network
across the globe in the network the
validations
of transaction is done by bitcoin users
called as miners sha-256 now blockchain
prevents unauthorized access by using a
hash function
called sha-256 to ensure that the blocks
are kept secure they are digitally
signed their hash value once generated
cannot be altered
now shk 256 it takes an input string
of any size and returns a fixed
length 256 bit output value and that is
the primary
feature of shf 256 encryption algorithm
you give any input it will always give
you
a 256 bit output and it is a one way
function
you cannot derive the input reversally
from the output what you have generated
and third is the proof of work
in blockchain mining is a process to
validate
transactions by solving a difficult
mathematical puzzle
called proof of work now in order to do
that the primary objective
of the minor is to determine the nonce
value and that nonce value is that
mathematical puzzle that miners required
to solve
in order to generate a hash which is
less than the target
defined by the network for a particular
block now in the bitcoin network
users trying to solve mathematical
puzzle are called as
minus now the puzzle is solved by
varying
a nonce which produces a hash value
lower than a predefined
condition which is called as the target
miners verify the transactions
and add the block to the blockchain when
confirmed and verified as of today the
miners
who solve the puzzle gets a reward of
12.5 bitcoins now once a block
is added to the blockchain the bitcoins
associated with the transactions
can be spent so once the block is
validated
then the transfer of bitcoins associated
with the transactions aggregated in the
block
the transfers are made then from one
account to the another now
in order to generate the hash let's see
you use the sha-256 hashing algorithm
you define the hash value if it is less
than the defined condition the target
then the puzzle
is deemed to be solved and if not then
you keep on incrementing nonce value and
you repeat the sh-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
define
generate the hash value again and you
keep doing this process till the time
you get the
hash value which is less than the target
now let's check an example
so for example beyonce wants to share 10
bitcoin with jennifer now in order to do
that
what will be the steps so beyond
transaction data is shared with bitcoin
users the miners from the
memory pool the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of
unmined transactions so in a memory pool
set of
unmined or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a
new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool
now miners competing to validate the
transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the
unconfirmed transaction pool they pick
up those transactions
and start validating those transactions
they aggregate in a data block and start
validating they start solving the puzzle
the miner who solves the puzzle first
shares his result
across the other nodes the other set of
miners
now once the block has been verified
the nonce has been generated then the
nodes will start granting their approval
if maximum nodes grant their approval
the block becomes valid
and is added to the blockchain now
simultaneously the miner who has
solved the puzzle will also receive the
reward in the meanwhile which will be of
12.5 bitcoin which as of today stands at
98k around dollars now the bitcoins the
10 btc for which the transaction was
initiated
now will get triggered and will get
transferred from beyond to jennifer now
let's take a look at certain
facts in proof of work a predefined
condition the target
is adjusted for every 2016 block which
is approximately
every 14 days and an average time to
mine a block is 10 minutes so basically
the target
keeps automatically adjusting itself to
keep the block generation
within the 10 minute time frame so this
is the representation so in order to
keep the
time frame for block generation within
10 minutes the target
keeps on adjusting itself now the
difficulty
of the puzzle changes the target changes
depending on the time it takes to mine a
block
so this is how a difficulty of a block
is being generated it is the hash target
of the first block
divided by the hash target of the
current block so this is the difficulty
which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically
it is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify
by the miners so once you have solved
the puzzle
and you have broadcasted that yes you
have earned you have validated a record
you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority
then the block gets validated and gets
added to the
blockchain now since the difficulty
depends on the hash target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block
as i said and as you can see in due
course
from the day of inception of bitcoin in
2009 till today
difficulty has increased exponentially
and it has been increasing
and thereby the entire effort of mining
and the computing power is also
increasing so as of
what was the resources which were
required to do mining
in 2009 you require more hashing power
more computing power
in order to do the mining today now what
if
someone tries to hack the data so let's
see blockchain
is a chain of blocks abc now each block
has solved a puzzle and generated a hash
value of its own which is its identifier
now
suppose a person tries to tamper a block
block b
and tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if
the data of the block will change the
hash value which is the digital
signature of the block
will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it
basically the blocks ahead of block b
will all get dealing because the
previous hash value
of block c will not remain valid
so in order for the hacker to make the
entire blockchain valid for the block b
which he has changed he has to change
the hash value of all the blocks ahead
of block b which will require
huge huge amount of computing power
which will be next to impossible so as
you see the results in the following
block
being invalid so with this whole thing
the blockchain
is making sure that the entire sequence
remains
non-hackable and prevent data
modification now
let's see what are the underlying
hardware requirements for
bitcoin mining and how the hardware is
evolved so in the early days
miners used to solve the puzzles using
regular processors
the controlling processor unit cpus now
but it used to take a lot of time
for mining though the difficulty levels
were low but still it used to take a lot
of time
now as i said the difficulties never
keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so this
discovered
that graphical processing units gpus
proved to be more efficient
than regular cpus so but this also had a
drawback
of consumption of electricity so any
miner who has to
calculate the return on investment on
the hardware he also has to
accommodate the cost of electricity and
other resources which are going in
in order to do the mining so finally as
of today
they are using a hardware called asic
application specific integrated circuit
which was specifically introduced for
mining
which consumes less power and has a
higher computing power and a better
hardware for mining so miners are
profitable
when their cost of resources to mine one
block
is less than the price of the reward
they receive so definitely
they have to have the investment less
than the reward what they earn so as of
today
in blockchain miners use their resources
to verify a transaction
they each time a block is mined new
bitcoins are
created in the network so the bitcoin
total supply is limited it is
at 21 million dollars approximately 21
million
bitcoin are in supply 17 to 18 million
bitcoins have already been mined
so only three to four million are left
as of today a reward of 12.5 bitcoin
is given to the miner on doing the
transaction
verification but the bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle
the reward given to a miner is half
every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so then
after that threshold is reached the
bitcoin reward will go down to 6.25
bitcoins so let's take an example of a
lottery ticket
where your chances of winning is
difficult so we are talking
about what is bitcoin mining pool your
chances of winning the lottery is
difficult
but in a community if individuals buy
multiple lottery tickets and pool their
tickets together
then this will increase their
probability and chances of winning more
so suppose you won the lottery
then based on the contribution the
reward is distributed among
all the participants bitcoin mining pool
is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together to mine a
block
now when a block is solved the miners
split the reward
equally based on the amount of
processing power they have invested so
it takes the pool members to generate a
final hash value then it checks how much
amount of work
was contributed by each pool member and
as a result
the bitcoin reward gets distributed
proportionally
amongst the participants now let's take
a look
at a demo on how can you see what is the
bitcoin reward
now this is a actual block of the
bitcoin network
as you can see this is a block and this
is the block reward 12.5 bitcoin so this
was a block which was mined
this is the block number and these
are the set of transactions which were
part
of this block now once this block was
mined by the miner
all these transactions then be done
these are the transfers of bitcoin from
one account to the other this is the
nonce which was generated by the miner
or the
mining pool in order to mine the block
and these are the other attributes and
if you take a look
at this url this is an example of a
mining pool
it's a demo account where the
participants
have shared their mining resources and
they are mining it in a pool and see
this is the reward
for which they are mining this is the
unconfirmed reward this is the confirmed
reward this is what they have already
validated and this is what they have
earned so far
so these are the hash these are the
block numbers which they have
mined so what are the key takeaways
today we learn about
what is bitcoin what is blockchain the
underlying technology of bitcoin what
are the concepts of bitcoin mining
how can you do bitcoin mining and the
demo on bitcoin mining i hope you all
had a great session and i'll meet you in
my next session thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here